[Music]
[Applause]
Vanessa Hudgens proved she's still got
it wicked
[Music]
the actress dusted off her highschool
musical skills for a karaoke rendition
of breaking free
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Vanessa took to Instagram on Sunday to
share the musical moment
writing um here's a really bad
aggressive and totally sober version of
breaking free
adding yep that happened lol it hurts my
ears but also makes me laugh lol
[Music]
yeah it's it was so much fun to make and
I think it really comes across on camera
it's a good time during an appearance on
the awards chatter podcast in April
Vanessa
opened up about her high school musical
days whatever happens as long as we're
together it's cool right
and her past relationship with her
co-star Zac Efron it started off really
organically and I could not have been
more grateful to have that relationship
at that time it was like this massive
phenomenon all the sudden and eyes were
on me and I it's just a really foreign
weird thing to go through and by being
in a relationship I feel like it kind of
kept me stabilized and grounded and I
had someone to lean on who was going
through it as well the two split in 2010
but not before she learned how to manage
relationship drama on a movie set I
remember one time we did have a fight
and it was while we were at her CIL's
and I remember Kenny Ortega coming
around the corner with the most
concerned look on his face like oh no is
our movie going to fall apart right now
like I said I pride myself on being a
professional so I was like that aside
we're just gonna move forward and do
what we need to do and we sorted it all
out but yeah I I think because I was so
young having that relationship really
stabilized me the two have since moved
on and dated other people she's a great
girl vanessa is with Austin Butler who
get this was in the high school musical
spin off shar peis fabulous adventure
how do you guys stay together
what's the core I think you just have to
it's it's important to put that other
person first and so if you're constantly
looking for ways that you can make them
happy and they're constantly looking for
ways that they can make you happy then
you kind of lift each other up as much
as possible and and then you can't go
wrong I don't think as for Zach he's
enjoyed playing the field do you believe
in love at first sight
I think so 100% it's a good thing to
believe it
[Music]